hello and welcome to this video or
stunts yeah his brother is probably
called West tons yeah and their cousins
North hands you never know okay so we
have the Kings Indian age three line
again I could go for the trade so it was
a bit boring huh no okay it's more
interesting I'm never sure about this
one to do Bishop g5 Bishop e3
yeah pretty unbalanced and tough
position here black is still is mixing
f5 and c6 hmm hmm okay it's normally not
such a great idea so what now Knight g4
is a move or Bishop g4 it's also
interesting even though yeah let's try
it's tough to figure out he's got moves
like Bishop d3 also my night before is
actually interesting hmm okay yeah I
have 94 while I was thinking and let's
just go for that and see what happens oh
it's always embarrassing if you miss a
move like that
hmm well 92 that's not necessarily fatal
I wonder if I can play this as some kind
of sacrifice here with Queen age 5 or
stuff like that or queen g-form want to
run into Knight f6 yeah it's a bit of an
awkward or could move 95 though I mean I
can do that night situ pinned it to
that's a completely crazy position let's
do that 92 king d 2 nite a one King
takes d3 yet completely wacky but
probably not even bad for me it's just
absolutely not the kind of position that
I can play well but we'll see what what
the result will be
yeah I think any absolutely does not
have to play the check on c2 you can
play all kinds of moves the bishop on d3
is also covering h7 this is an important
detail so move like Queen to h5 is not
threatening made for example check yeah
so it goes for it if you can take III by
the way that is an interesting idea so
pawn takes has also rook f2 okay King
III mmm I have to do this if he for some
it's looking dangerous okay he has that
check can go nitey for maybe on age 5 h
525 now that doesn't look right I have
to prepare it some somehow i wonder if
that chick is so dangerous
Keeney one should be playable covering
g5 so that I can possibly play age five
yeah that was an idea of course you see
one let's look F to Vlad III Hanks oops
oops that's a big boobs
magic he is very often I see that hangs
but I have to cover be to summer and
probably getting killed
hours Jack it's still struggle with that
line I mean even though I often have
pretty good positions i guess the the
type of position is just completely not
my my kind of domain between before is
just winning would be weird if he
doesn't see it check
strong
now I've got no reply nice rosanna tree
awful pretty awful yeah and that's it
simply not my kind of position actually
think that this is pretty bad for Black
Sea 6 + f5 it's not not a good
combination of moves but I simply didn't
play it well probably this is just a bad
idea i think i've i've tried this in
other games and it didn't work out
either this is a position that if you
played with black oil named Ariel's give
an engine too wide and you're getting
killed I mean not just the human also
engine whirs engine because objectively
speaking this is just a bad King stop
was just wants to do this and gives
white a pretty big edge it's the normal
kind of move I mean if he enters that I
have 93 and this is bad very bad yeah
Bishop g4 is probably a bad idea and
this is at least them yeah for me yeah I
did I didn't really think about night
before I process pretty pretty awful
check and so here here when the engine
still think this is kind of equal but a
Quincy form afternoon Queenie to this is
already losing after Queen B 6 it's also
why i felt i really have to cream you
six i didn't see anything remotely play
along and maybe here i can still fight
even though this that looks awful
h5 yeah it so it's a mess Bishop g4 is
not good just too slow i guess and gives
away that d 3 square and such an such a
drastic way and i have to have to adjust
my way of playing here not go for Bishop
g4 again ok thanks for watching